there I am with my arm literally past my
elbow inside a cow and you know it's
deep huh it didn't occur what are you
trying to what is this part of uh it's
not like a crystal ball thing is it
I don't think so man I think that that
episode we were uh we were showing the
realities of artificial insemination oh
yeah and I was trying to make the point
that you know there there is no
McDonald's
there is no Carl's Jr there there are no
millions and millions of hamburgers
served every day without people coaxing
the sperm out of a bull and and getting
it into a cow yeah I mean it it's it's
so prevalent and so common
um in the places where it happens but
but so mysterious to most people from
one or the other yeah yeah get it
getting the you know I mean you're
talking about artificial vaginas you're
talking about uh styrofoam cups you're
talking about you know guiding the penis
of a bull called hun sucker Commando
into the right spot how big is it can
you put it around like a can you get one
hand all the way around it or not yeah
the Bulls are interesting it's like a
carrot I was a place called Babcock
Ranch in Texas where we did the same
thing with uh quarter horses and
thoroughbreds and what's that ponies No
Quarter Horse is a is a big animal that
runs the quarter mile okay as opposed to
a thoroughbred who would run you know
Belmont Stakes Preakness things yeah I
was just that kneeling yeah yeah they
keep changing the name of it but I was
there fast horses man fast horses well
they but the quarter horses are bigger
now they're about the same size okay
they're just um they're they're
cardiovascular systems are a little
different they're musculature is a
little different they're just bred to
run faster for shorter periods yeah a
little Urban but they brought in this
horse called paid by chick I still don't
know why they call it that but this was
season one of dirty jobs you can find
this too I'm wearing a yellow bicycle
helmet because the day before a groom
got kicked unconscious oh why because he
got underneath the horse the wrong way
way look it gets violent so the the
horses let in
and then it it jumps on something called
a pommel horse like that's literally
where they oh yeah I've seen those
things in the Olympics so the front legs
get on top of this thing now meanwhile
they bring in a mare in heat
so it's like you know in a handsome
animal so like it's like porn it's like
black beauty is let in she's in heat you
bring in the stallion oh yeah he jumps
up on the quarter horse and he just
starts thrusting in midair I mean he's
fully ready to go yeah and that's when
you step in
you meaning me with a yellow bicycle
helmet holding a an artificial vagina oh
like some kind of damn spunk minion it
looked
so you're hunched under this animal and
and and this is not like a bull's little
carrot penis this is a full-on baby's
arm holding an app you have to rest on
your shoulder or anything like how heavy
is it yeah well you get your shoulder
underneath the animal then you grab the
penis and you slip it into the
artificial vagina which looks like a hot
water bottle oh yeah and now here's the
craziest part about that on the other
side of the artificial vagina you've got
a baby bottle like a formula baby bottle
that screws in and inside that baby's
bottle is a um a plastic bag so all the
sperm from the artificial vagina drains
into the baby bottle and into the bag oh
inside it's
there's like 35 000 worth of spoogelotti
right like in your hand like stat
um and uh and yeah the strangest thing
this and my favorite artifact from Dirty
Jobs that I actually auctioned off a few
years ago from my Foundation was that
baby bottle 14 years old
filled with the sperm from this horse
called paid by chick and I and I used to
keep it I used to keep it on my mantel
oh yeah in San Francisco where I lived
in my apartment and the afternoon sun
Theo it would come through the window
and it would pick up that crystallized
semen and that baby bottle and throw the
most beautiful little rainbows across
the living room unreal little sperm
prisms it was amazing
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one